Zaka Mula Khar Doctor Zakir Naik For Your
Vital And Emoticon Speech On Reading Al
Quran With
Understanding Zaka Mula Khar Allah Subhan Taala God Bless The
Mighty Rid Of You With His
Blessings For Your Earnest And Attentive Listening
To The Talk I Am Certain The Same Would Continue
In The Inshallah More Interesting Question
And Answer Session Your Opportunity
To Cross Question Dr Zakir Naik Your
Opportunity To Ask Clarification Not Yet
Spoken And Any Other Question You Have
On The Topic You May Ask More Questions In
The Available Time We Have You Need To Follow The
Following
Rules Kindly
Note One Your Question Should Be On The Topic Al
Quran Should Be Read With
Understanding Only Only
On The Topic If You Have General
Questions You May Ask Inshallah We Have The A
Doctor Zakir  And open exclusively open question
answer session reserved two questions
for tomorrow not for today
second point your question should be
brief and to the point preferably framed in
one to five sentences this is question
time for you not a lecture and thesis
discussion time please note third point
your question should be only one at a time
for your second question you need to go back
at the queue and line up again and await your
chance we have three mikes arranged in this open
ground two for gents one close to me in
front of the gents section for the gents the
second question mic for the gents is in the
rear section of the gents we have the third
mic in the ladies section in front of the
ladies seating for the ladies to put forward their
questions on
non muslims would be given first
preference to put forward their questions
volunteers at the mikes are requested to
Kindly ensure that the same is
implemented formally and kindly
state your name and
profession before putting forward your
question to Doctor Zakir May we have the
first question on the mic number
one Doctor Zakir your name and profession
please first Vinod Shah is my name I am
professionally a spiritual healer I am
doing aura photography and psychic surgery
surgery without cut this is at least the
spiritual science we can say medical science
is the science of medicine and spiritual science
is the science of human body it body mind and
soul what we say is the science of God power once
the person develops spiritual power by sadhna what ever
the prayer spiritual prayer and what ever the namaz and what ever we are doing and
if you develop the spiritual ability to heal
others this is the difference between ordinary
human being and super human being what ever
and science of  This energy invisible
energy now there are two type of things which
exist in human being one is visible
physical body and another soul body so now
science of the body is 99% and science of
the body is % today what we are practicing
medical science science of medicine and not the
science of human body and purpose of any
religion is to keep human body healthy throughout the
life and achieve the final goal of the
life so understand the science of enable power god power
sir can we have any question without a
background so just you can have any
background in two three sentences then why please if we
follow the path of religion any religion
and Quran we can keep our self
healthy through the life if we don't get any disease
in the body then he is a healer and he heals things without
cutting with a knife and
treating here talking about
spirituality healing of the body healing of
the soul  Basically brother as for us spiritual
healing is concern there is something like true
spiritual healing and something which is like a disease the
word of difference is that we do have many
spiritual healing in
public done by missionaries and in some
of the programs attended by Christian missionaries they get a
person and they get on the stage and the person
is lame and he starts walking the person is blind he starts
and we find many and I did not
know any
document which tried to expose how they do it how they do it
and in our Islamic church
foundation or research organization na ilam
and kapan and let material coming there many
documentaries show how they do it how they make
a fool of the
public for
each they show a person that the person is lame
setting in
audience the healer goes and picks up the stick
in the name of Jesus starts running and the
person starts running but the person also starts
running  The person tongue on the right the person was
sitting on the
left what we realize that the pre
plan is the pre plan what I tell them really if
you are a spiritual healer you come to a
hospital a medical doctor I tell them come to a
hospital directly if you
treat the whole family will
convert so if you are a spiritual
healer and it is really true we require all
people like you we don't have to have a government hospital or a government hospital or a government hospital or a government hospital or a government hospital or a government hospital or a government hospital or a government hospital or a government hospital or a government hospital or a government hospital or a government hospital or a government hospital or a government
doctor but doing this surgery without using
laser technology but using
laser technology a lot of things I'm talking about
I'm a medical doctor coming from a
medical background if it was true we would learn
in medical first year then this  Method so we would prefer having more such
people than
spending on a hard there what it is necessary to
set most of the things people take in speech
healing it is more of a big fast it is to make fast but fast
money but but the mighty God
Mashallah there is Quran we can get
peace for you in your
mind and you can treat certain
diseases which science can not understand but
science is understanding there but what we see
today mostly in the sphere healing is in was it nothing but people heal at if let us go to
hospital rather than and you heal people better have
doctors healing generally means healing is
not for treating the disease in body but we
treat the mind and soul body or never the
disease through out the life so preventive care
what we do day to day prayer and namaz and what ever we do it
properly we will  Never
get a health problem and if you
understand the science behind it it is the
science of God power and how to use God
power in our day to day life what is the relation
of God power with human body so if you
understand that science totally what is 99%
of human health medical science has not understood
the mind and soul science because it is
western science it is science of body only
and it is one part of total knowledge 99% of
knowledge is mind and soul knowledge which is a
secret knowledge lost from India and today what
I am a science student I gave up
my religion by going to temple
and other thing for 20 years after learning this
science and when I came to know about
the spiritual healing about reiki and
pranic healing and I came from the foreign this
foreign people are teaching our own science in
India the science which was there in 5000
years in  India Vedic Science Jainism
Muslim What ever that is lost because
western science judge took over the charge of our
human body and human health and this
science was discovered to kill virus and
bacteria only it is a chemical poison
brother this is a question answer time not a
speech time so we have got your question you are saying that if you know this
spiritual
healing you will never get the disease of the body
I
disgrace if you do practice there may be on certain okase there are less
chances that you acquire dis but if you say that you will never get
dis I degree with you I degree with you what you have to
believe I do not they are certain
for each you speak about namaz I can give a talk of one are
on the scientific benefits of
sala I can give a talk of one are on the
scientific benefits of sala for each the
best  In Sujood
you put the lowest part of the
face on the lowest part of the ground and
when we do that what we find is that there is
more supply of the blood going to the brain that makes
a healthy brain there are less chances
of having chills because that is the disease of the
skin of the face when you are doing Sujood there
is drainage of the blood there are less
chances of having brain ulcers now when we
breathe normally when we breathe normally
1 lb of the air in the lung remains it is called resid air when you
breathe in the sujood
the abdominal viscera they press against the drum and
the drum it expels the resid air so you
breathe in more fresh air so because you breathe
in more fresh air they give less resp the chances your
lung will be healthy are superior less
chances  Of having lung does more then they increase
venous return of the abdominal viscera there are less
chances of having piles once you get
up from the position of sijda once you stand
up there is more stress on the qa muscle and the qa
muscle in medical science they are known as pray
heart it is the blu to lo part of the body i
can go on giving references how does
salah
benefit but if we muslims we do pray sala
benefit we pray because we thank allah
sula medical benefit a side dish or our
main dish biryani is because we thank allah
and we worship him its
medical benefits may inspire a
non muslim himself to come closer to Islam it will keep
you healthy but mainly it is to thank
allah subhana taala because we worship him it
is not because we have to exercise these are
extra benefits side dishes but even if we talk about other religions
about  Vedic and all some I do agree do have some
benefits but to say that if you do this you will never get any
disease I degree with it and it has not been
proven by science at all and is for the non
muslims if they would like to ask any question even
outside the topic if he or she
is a non muslim you are most welcome to ask
question in outside the topic ho answer the question may be the
next question
from the brother in the rear salam awaikum
sir my name is SK Ranjani deputy
engineer government of Maharashtra water
supply department I am non islamic
my questions are why the religion are
[music]
created for human t my opinion in this is
that for peace one needs knowledge and wisdom
thanks sir brother the question that why are there so many religions
first question and
after he made a comment that peace the solution
Hani the tagline of Peace TV is For Peace you
require knowledge and wisdom and they do agree with
us. For the first part question concern that why there are so many religions if you
believe that almighty God is our creator Allah
subhana ta'ala is the only reason
Allah says in the Quran in surah ul-Islam
chapter number 19 verse number 19 islam the only reason the only way
of life acceptable in the
sight of God is submitting a will to God
Almighty God only says on one religion and
all the messengers that came right from Adam
Ibrahim Moses Jesus Muhammad Peace be upon them all of them is nothing
but submitting your will
to Almighty God now in Arabic one a
person submits to Almighty God he is called as
a Muslim and the religion of Islam comes from the
root wad salaam wa mees peace it also comes
from the Arabic word silam which  Means
to submit your will to Almighty God so
Islam in short means peace is acquired by
submitting to Almighty God so Almighty God is our creator there is only one religion
but by the passage
of time the scripture kept on getting
changed there was interpolation there was fabrication
and when ever the scripture kept
on changing as Allah says in the Quran
in Sura Baqarah chapter number two verse number
7 Allah mt d
le suction man in p o time instruction
le lama cha na when the message got corrupted Almighty God sent a
new messenger and a new
message this kept on happening till Almighty God is the
last and final messenger
Prophet Muhammad Peace be upon him and last
and final message that is the glo Quran the
messenger the came previously and bled the
mighty God from 124000 messengers n the
face of the earth by name only  25 In the Quran
the others we don't know may be someone ask me that can you
consider you
coming from Hindu background if you ask me
can you consider Ram is a messenger of God
and can you consider Shri Krishna to be the
messenger of God I say since his name is not
mentioned in the Quran and Hadith I don't know may be he was not I can not say for sure but
the point is to note all the
messengers that came before Prophet Mohammad
peace be upon him they were only sent for two
people and that time so even if Ram was a
messenger of God even if Krishna was a messenger
of God he was sent for two people
and that time today all the human beings are
respectful whether they live in India and in
America and Saudi Arabia and Canada and
UK any part of the world they should follow the
last and final messenger Prophet Mohammad
sallallahu alaihi wa sallam and last and final message
that is the glorious
Quran and Allah have taken a promise in Sara
Hijr Chapter number 15 verse number na that have
reel the Quran and will ga from corruption so
almighty God there is only one religion that is
submitting your will to God Islam means peace acquired
by submitting will to God and you
said peace can be acquired by knowledge and
wisdom yes knowledge from us the best God is almighty God our
creator who is the most
wise al hakim it is Allah subhan l mighty God
so the best peace can be given to you is
by following the knowledge and guidance of our
creator Allah subhan taala hope to answer the
question thank
you yes sister good evening sir my name is
Manju Singh I would like to ask you one question a first
of all that I would like to tell you something that I have seen
your
videos that is Hinduism  Similarities with
Islam so I would like to ask you
what is the difference if any non Muslim
will read with understanding of Vedas and he or
she should read with understanding of Al Quran so it is
necessary that the non Muslim should go with that Al
Quran so good question what is the
importance of reading the Vedas with
understanding like how I gave talk on Al
Quran should understanding and the sister saw
my video cassette the DVD on similarity
between Islam and Hindu and sister reached the end of
my talk I told and I
requested the government of India I said that you should teach
Sanskrit as a language
unforced
language only a handful of people no I
requested the government of India to teach
Sanskrit so that the Hindu reads the Vedas and neither they
read the Vedas they will come closer to the
mighty God when
you read the Hindu scripture the
Hindu scripture says these Upanishads  It is mentioned in
Chhand Upanishad Chapter Number Six Section Number
Two Verse Number Oneam Viyam God is only one without a
second It is mentioned in Sveta Sveta
Upanishad Chapter Number Six Verse Number Nine Nach Kaj
Janita Dapa of That God He has got no
superior He has got no parents Almighty
God has got no father He has got no mother It is mentioned in
Sveta Upanishad Chapter Number Four Verse
Number 19 Naat Pratima of That God There is no
Pratima Pratima Sanskrit means Image
Photograph Picture Painting Sculpture Idol
According to Tasta Upanishad Chapter Number Four
Verse Number 19 says Na Tas Pati As of That
God There is no image There is no picture There is no
painting There is no portrait There is
no sculpture There is no statue There is no
idol Same thing Yajurveda Chapter
Number 32 Verse Number Tha Naat Pati Masti of
That God there is no image so I am asking
you sister that if you read your Hindu
scripture without adding only
chanting the verses insha Allah you will come
closer to God and insha Allah you will submit to
God and if you read Hindu scripture it
mentions Hindu scripture I can give a lot of
references it talks about the coming
of the last and final messenger prophet
Mohammad peace be upon him if you read the
Bhavishya Purana parvath section 1 chapter 1 loka 2
to 8 it speaks about Salam it mentions in
Bhavishya Purana parvath section 1
loka 10 27 now coming of
age in book number 20 number 127 r number
14 prof in ave book number 20 number 21 number a
only reference can keep in mind that in it
now mentions Ahmad Ahmad mean one
and he mentions several places if you read
Uttar Chik Mantra number  1500 It Speaks
About Ahmad Mu'lam If You Read Indra Chapter
Number Two Verse 152 It Speaks About Ahmad If You
Read Indra Chapter Number 31 Verse Number 19
It Speaks About Ahmad He Also Prophesies A
Nara Shansa Nara means Man Shansa means
Praiseworthy Nara Shansa means a Person Who
Praiseworthy If You Translate Arabic It Is
Mohammad So Muhammad Sallam Is Mentioned
By Name As Nara Shansa In Several Places In
Rigveda Book Number One Him Number 13 Verse Number
Th In Rigveda Book Number One Him Number 18 Verse
Number Na In Rigveda Book Number Two Him Number Thi
Verse Number Two In Rigveda Book Number Se
Him Number Two Verse Number Two In Yajurveda
Chapter Number 20 Verse Number 37 Yajurveda
Chapter Number 20 Verse Number 57  Yajurveda
Chapter No. 21 Verse No. 31 Juzr Chapter
No. 28 Verse No. 19 I can go on taking
only references from the Hindu script about coming as I must
understand Sanskrit and if I read
sank scripture
I understand you submit to God I don't have any
idea and have to follow the last and
final messenger prophet mohd pass his ho
questioner thank you
next queen from any brother non muslim
brother next mic de someone any non
muslim brother here we will
not the next mic yes brother I am
asking on the beha of non muslim
brother ok we will not that so he is like any other he did not
believe in God and what he said is that we don't
believe in Quran and you should not
believe in God why in this 21st century you are
believing in almighty God this in modern era
the science technology is that much higher than we should
you  Believe in God you should not believe in
God you should do what is better for human beings
thank you badar the question on baha
friend na athi that we believe in god in
this age of science and technology you no be a
good human being brother the farthing all do i a create
your
friend why because most of the human beings
unfortunately they are having blind belief he is a
hindu b father is hindu he is a
christian b father is a christian some people are muslim b
father is muslim this friend
of yours is christian thinking he may be coming
from religious background but he may not agree with the
god and his parents worship them being called
a god so the reason is he is because he
said the first part
of the islamic shahada la ila dere i no gad the only thing i have to do is
proof la ba
allaah i il d inshallah so this person half
my job is done to the  Other non Muslim first to
prove to him that God is false God
and then prove to Allah this
non Muslim not even half my job is done he already said
the first part of the
Islamic Shahada La ilaha de is no God the only thing have to do with Allah but
Allah will say
Inshallah na sus you said your friend believe
in science and technology and the world is
advancing I will ask the question that
suppose an equipment is in
front of him which no one in the world has ever seen
and if the question is asked to your friend that who will be
the first person who will be able to tell you the name
of this equipment which
no one in the world has who is the first person
and the answer he will give he may set the
manufacturer and from him the eventer and from him
the creator and from him the maker what ever he say it will be some
Similar to the
creator maker manufacturer eventer what ever it may be
similar and the second person who ever
the creator inventor manufacturer
told he will be the second person but the
first person would be the creator the
manufacturer the eventer keep this answer at the
back of your mind and ask him the next
question that how did our universe come
into existence so he will tell you that you have not
advanced and we have come to know that
our universe was once a primary nebula then there was a
big bang then there was a secondary
separation and gave rise to galaxies the stars the
sun the moon and the earth on which we live one did you come to know this he will tell you it was
in 1973 a
group of scientists describe the big
bang and the creation of the universe so you tell me what you came
to know hardly now  35 36
Years Back It is already mentioned in Quran 1400 Years
Ago in Ambiya Chapter number 21 Verse number 3
Sayad Nawab Sama
Sanaba That the heaven and the earth were joined together
and we close together Who could have mentioned this
in the Quran 1400 Years Ago So the same may be it was a
fluke Don't argue continue ask
the next question What
is the shape of the Earth So he will tell you
Previously the human beings thought that the earth
on which we live is flat It was in 1579 one
Sir Francis Drake when he sailed around the earth he
proved that the earth is spherical
you came to know in
1579 Hardly 400 Years Back Quran Mention 14
Ago It is mentioned in Quran Inner Naya Chapter number 79
number
30 And there after we made the  and it does not refer to a normal egg and we know
today that the world is not
completely round like a ball it is satin from
the pole it is geospherical in shape and the Arabic word dahaha does refer to a normal egg it
specifically refers to the egg of an
ostrich and if you ask the shape of an egg of an ostrich
that too is geospherical in
shape imagine the Quran speaks about the
geospherical shape of the earth 1400 years ago you have a
friend who could have mentioned this in the
Quran he will say that he may be your prophet
Muhammad PBUH he was an intelligent man don't argue continue you ask him the light of
the moon is it its own light and
reflected light so he will tell you that
Previously Human Beings Thought The Light
Of The Moon Is Its Own Light Recently In
Science 100 Years Back 200 Years Back 3 Years Back We Came To Know
That The Light Of The Moon Is
Not Its Own Light It Is A Reflected Light
What You Came To Know Recently Is Mentioned In
The Quran 149 Years Ago In Surah Furqan
Chapter Number 25 Verse Number 16 From Quran
The Light Of The Moon Is Its Own Light And The Light Of The
Moon Is Described As Munir And Noor Meaning By Name
Light And Reflection Of Light So Do Hai
mention the light of the moon is not its own light
but reflected light 14 years ago slip and say ok may be
your prophet was very very
intelligent n continue i learn
in school the sun is in the
system in the galaxy it does not rotate about its axis it was not i
learn in school
1982 27 y bak i n dan wa stationery
b Quran aya number 21 number
33 it is cut the not and
day
m one light is inverted with motion b means it
describes the motion of a moving body
Quran says the sun and the moon besides
revolve it even rotate about its own
axis and today science has come to know that the
sun takes
approximates who could have mentioned this in the
Quran 1400 years back which we come to know recently hardly
20 years back 30 years
back he gave a  Pause Don't wait for the answer You
can
continue Quran speaks about the sky
Almighty God has made a protected ceiling
Without it life cannot exist on the face
of the earth In Ambiya Chapter number 21 Verse
number 32 Quran speaks about water cycle in
cell places In the Quran in Sura Amar Chapter
39 Verse number 21 In Sura Ruma Chapter number
30 Verse number 24 In Sura Hi Chapter 15 22 In Sura
Moman Chapter 23 Verse number 18 In Sura Char
24 Number 40 In Sura Chapter number 7 57 From the
Quran speaks about the water cycle in
great detail Who could have mentioned this 14
years back He gave a pause Don't argue Keep on
continuing Quran speaks about
biology that we have
created every plants in pace to end
In Sexes Male and Female In Sir Taha
Chapter No. 20 Verse No. 53 Quran
Speaks About That The Animals Have Been Created
From Water In Sir Noor Chapter 24 Verse
No. 45 Quran Speaks About The Yaman B B Could Form
Water In Sir Furqan Chapter 25 Verse No.
54 The Quran Speaks About Genetics That
It Is The Male Fluid Which Is Responsible
For Determining The Sex Of The Child In Sir
Najm Chapter No. 53 Verse No. 45 To 46 And
Sir Qayam Chapter No. 75 Verse No. 37 To
39 The Quran Speaks About Embryology The
Quran Speaks About Geology The Quran
Speaks About Oceanology You Can Give A Talk
For A Together After Every Scientific Sign
Mentioned In Quran Ask Your Friend Who Could Have
Mentioned This In The Quran 14 Years Back  Only
reply I can give you is the creator the
manufacturer the maker the inventor this creator this manufacturer this inventor we
muslims call allah we call mahim
god so today science is not eliminating god
it is eliminating models of god la ilaha
illallah that is why famous philosopher by the name
of fr s bakan said little knowledge of
science ya est b inpath knowledge of science b y cl or la gdak
fr u si mdi kse in god wad
and quran madan sa proving aba la
suave we request non muslim brothers and
sisters if you are curious why this book al
quran it should be read compare to so many other
readings you have ch may be more engaging more interesting more
thrilling for you feel
free this is your opportunity to as we have
doctor zakir nayak on this side and this is
your session i  I am here to help you
clarify and help you get a proper answer Insha
Allah, I will give the next question
from the sister's side Assalamu Alaikum
brother, any non Muslim sister, this question
is on behalf of a non Muslim
friend named Deepti, she is working in a call
centre, excuse me if any non Muslim
brother or sister here who has some
reservations is not coming in front on the mic, we would allow them to put a question
through your
friend and if you are there, question slips are
available in the area with a volunteer, feel free
to write your questions I would request the
volunteer to kindly have slips
presented and shown in your hand so they can get
the slip from you, put your question on
the slip, have it sent down to me on the
stage and Insha Allah the more interesting
one from them, we would put it forward to
Dr Zakir Butt  It is more preferable if you ask
on the mic so that is not that I am playing
around with the slips and jangling with them
and putting the more easy question than friend yes sister
every question is it is compulsory for
me to accept Islam to read the Quran can
I read the Quran without accepting Islam
good but is it compulsory for me to
accept Islam to read the Quran and can I read
the Quran without accepting Islam aa my take the
Quran wa read a dos to the whole of hati it is
not necessary that you have to be a Muslim to read
the Quran b inshallah if you read the Quran
with an open mind and an open mind inshallah inshallah aaran inshallah accept
Islam that is the reason you read
Islam in an interview said that it is good that I
read the Quran before meeting the
Muslims he read the Quran accept Islam if you have
met the Muslim buffer in the Quran  May be
aked
Ilam Quran is the best app it is the
guidance for whole of hati and your friend can very well
read the translation of the Quran in
the language understand the best and if have any
query most welcome to ask on the email
and to foundation
adnet ho que a
clarify for dos na no brother
Yusuf Islam i the same person cat steven the very
famous one of the leading pop singers
british pop singers yes sister this is a
question from a student my sha in the
diance today and she was like no
friday given more
importance why is friday more important ekli eli ha
kri jade so muslim i
different pro fa
er friday
hut
no cam and it ga the
lanner wa flood no friday is a way bafit but in
islamic qtest it is the weekly important
day in which we have the congregation
sala and darshan sala is more important nuly wa
phra day but was wak wa r  Jamaat Sala is bigger during
Weekly Eid and it is compulsory that we pray
in the morning and in that Juma Sala like we had to in
the afternoon Imam gives him
speech and gives guidance the weekly guidance to
the Muslims what is required he takes about
local and all things are important and
convey the message so Friday basically is weekly
Eid weekly main day of the Muslims yes
brother good evening sir my name is Rohit
Raina sir basically I am Hindu and I just recently
converted to Islam and not only because
I am in love with a Muslim girl
not only because of those problems and all the problems that is because I
accept Islam from the
bottom of my heart and I tell you frankly I don't know about
Arabic I don't know about
Urdu from the very beginning and I don't know about
the Sanskrit also because I am
from the Hindu background now  I want to
learn about Islam not only because I am
going to be married to a Muslim girl and
why the controversies are there so much in the nature that people are
creating not God is
creating that controversy and God is
not giving the message to people that do all the harm if
a non Muslim marries a Hindu Muslim
girl and if a non Muslim Hindu marries a
Muslim girl so why the controversies are there
and if I accept Islam then there is
no problem
in their family also so why there must be lot
of controversies so please
explain me the question that did you
accept Islam recently and you are in love
with the Muslim girl but that was not the main reason he
accepted Islam from the heart he himself
understood Arabic he did not know
Sanskrit but it is not compulsory the yes no
Arabic to go to know it not Kapri  But at
present I am translating English to
Arabic. I said it is not compulsory for a
person who knows Arabic to go to Jannah.
I said if you don't know Arabic you can understand the Quran
the best. If you don't know Arabic you can understand the Quran in the
best way. If you know English you can read the
Quran in the best way. If you know Hindi you can read the Quran in the best way. If you know Hindi you can read the Quran in the best way. If you know Hindi you can read the Quran in
the best way. I have to do minimum translation of Quran in the best way. If
the Muslims
are concerned about the controversy, I am not telling about the
Muslim controversy. I am
telling about the Hindu controversy. Why I am saying this?
Inara Bakra
Chatter Number 221 from the Quran it says do not marry
an idol worshipper till he
believes a believing man even if he becomes even if he is a
slave he is far better than idol
worshipper even if he also loves you and the same is
vice versa for the girl and for the boy the reason it is you have
vehicle and one type of vehicle is of the
vehicle and the other of the vehicle is the vehicle run but
naturally the ta should be similar and but naturally any good person girl would want the husband to go
to heaven so found the way to
heaven is by submitting all
mighty gods what have requested you and
that reason you accepted Islam as far as
the Hindus are concerned you have to show them this
video cassette similarities between Islam and
Hinduism what I tell them
No people talk about interfaith I tell them at least agree I tell
the non Muslims you know I don't
believe in interfaith dialogue that
Islam is the same religion as Hinduism as
Christianity all are same I don't agree with that I can stop and see the
difference What
I tell them at least agree that one book
is 100% the word of God The Quran will say I don't mind believing
that Bible is 100% the word
of God The Hindu will say I don't mind believing Vedas
to be the word of God The
Muslim will say I don't agree that
Quran is the word of God So I tell them that what is common
in the Scripture let us agree
to follow 100% what is different What
interfaith them at least agree is
100% and one we read Scripture All
Scripture sets there is one God
From the Scriptures there is a mighty God, there are no images, no
idols, no statues. So let us all agree
to believe and worship one God, there is no image,
no idol. From the Scriptures there is the Vedas, the
Bible, the Quran, the last one. The final
messenger, prophet, peace be upon him. If you
read the Bible, Jesus, peace be upon him. He said,
mention the Gospel of John, chapter number 16, verse
number 12 to 14. He said, I have many things to say to you, but he
cannot be them now,
for he is the Spirit of truth shall come, he shall
guide that, he shall not speak of himself. There shall he speak, he shall show you things
to come now. Here
Jesus, peace be upon him, is telling you, I have many things to say to you,
but you cannot grasp my message, only one. The Spirit
of truth shall come, he shall guide that.  Talking
About Prophet Mohammad Peace Be Upon Him The
Scriptures of All The Major World Religions Hinduism Christianity Judaism
Islam All of Them Say There Is
One God You Have to Worship
Him Alone and the Last and Final Messenger
Prophet Mohammad Peace Be Upon Him So If All The
Religious People Read The Scripture Insha
Allah This Conflict Would Be Solved and All of Them Would Acquire Peace
by Submitting the Will to
Almighty God Hope Yes
Any Non Muslim Brother or
Mic Any Sister Alam Walekum This is the Beha
of a Non Muslim Sister Every Question is there are certain
verses in the Hindu Scriptures
Ch Speak of
Monm Verses Thy Rar Some Ch Speak of the Po So
Every Question is there are certain
verses Ch
Good Quote Thy
Rar in Us Sk Mano
Badot Aa Aa Aa Most Has in All Am Lu
Scriptures I Veda A Way Arp
Other Scriptures We Are Low Down  In
authority do speak about
patham do speak about scripture but a logic if they follow
the higher theory and what I said in my formula
I said what is differing decisions then so in if there is any verse on scripture then no verse on scripture should go away we are talking about
common and
lazy how one should listen to the
Quran and one should listen to the scriptures and then
Hindus decide that they should follow the scriptures
not consider the Quran with any one because it has been from anyone
besides Allah there has been many
contradictions there have been many
mistakes so how can a word of God have
contradictions so if there is any contradiction
you have to reject that scripture it is easy
and if you follow my formula I
am taking only that which is common I can give
a logical speech talking about differences in
Islam and  Hinduism but I have not come here
to bring the differences I am come here
to get the similarities Balma God say in Quran how to
speak with other people in nature
64 come come first am aych firstam a ala na am ada ella bak bana muslim that
we are muslim saying at
Allah sula so this is a formula seen in
the Quran how to speak with different types
of people that come to come in terms differences
we can discuss tomorrow today we come to common
terms and let us agree to follow what is common so I am
picking up those vs those that are
matching with the Quran if there is a construction I
reject that scripture I don't consider it to be
the word of God but because the Hindu consider it
to be the word of God I am taking from the
scripture hope answer the question
sister yes brother good evening Mr Zakir
Nayak  My name is Gulab Chand Vishwakarma and
I have a
question Bakrid is very near this
time and Muslims believe that not the ozone of
goat they sacrifice the goats buffalo and
cows and that and according to Islam
humanity and humanity is very important and everyone should be kind to
animals and human beings
and then I have these then I give
sacrifice of goats cows and buffalos and not the ozone
of goat whether they should do it in favor of
cattle and cattle humanity good then why are we sacrificing
goats and goats no can we sacrifice good if they do not on Bakrid they
sacrifice they kill animals and I am asking you the question that I am not Bakrid if you
sacrifice animals it is allowed no generally why is it a
direct question why do you have non
veg correct no  No I am not getting what
you are saying your main question is why do you have
non veg why do you have
meat actually I want to say no to the o'clock of
Bakrid and other o'clock as well
ok no to the o'clock of Bakrid Allah says in Quran
in Haj chapter number 22 that the blood and the
meat do not go to Allah it is your party we
go to Allah so unlike other ridges in other ridges they
sacrifice they sacrifice the goat
and keep an altar in the name of diety and who is
god
in Islam no we sacrifice what we do the
compulsory minimum we have to give to the poor
people and we have to give to the relatives and
friends no you can keep for yourself then
maximum you can keep it for yourself if you want to give fully all you can give so one we are
sacrifice  what are we doing we are
benefiting the human and we are giving them
food to eat nor giving food to eat is good
and bad
brother giving food to the other people to eat is it
good and
bad in hati it is good and bad good so there
ilam is the reason of hati now you ask the
question what about killing animals it is
good for hati but what about
animals in short a muslim can be a very good
muslim even by being a pure traditon
it is not compulsory in ilam you should have
non veg but this almighty god has given us
permission to have non veg why should we not have
non veg from Allah in the Quran in ra madha
chapter number five verse number one it of the four
footed animal which has been made lawful for you
Allah says in sri lan chapter number 16 verse
number five that the cattle has been made for you so that
you benefit from them and  Of the meat you
can eat the same message is repeated in Sir Muminoon
chapter number 23 verse number 21 that in the
cattle instructive sign from the belly you
drink milk and of the meat you eat so since
almighty God has given us permission why should we not have it not
coming to the logical
aspect today science tells us that in
non veg food in flesh food is rich in
vitamins
and it is only food which has gut complete
protein our human body there are total 23
amino acids required by the human
body out of which they are not synthesized in the
body it has to be given from the external
diet there is no vegetarian food which gives you all
the 8 amino acids it is the flesh food the
non veg food which gives you all the 8 amino acids
further more if you analyze the set of teeth of the vegetarian animals
cow goat sheep have gut flat set
of  They only have vegetables they can digest flesh If we
analyze the set of teeth of the carnivorous animals tiger, leopard, lion they have
gut
pointed set of teeth they have gut a low set of teeth they have
cannon set of teeth they only have
flesh food they can have vegetables if we see
a set of teeth we have gut
pointed pad teeth and well flat teeth we have gut
omnis set of teeth If almighty God wanted us to have
only vegetables he would give us the pointed
teeth for what we have
the flesh food further the digestive system
of the carnivorous animals cow, goat, sheep can only
digest vegetables they can digest flesh
food the digestive system of the carnivorous animals tiger, leopard, lion
can only digest
flesh food they can digest vegetables but the
digestive system of the human being has gut
small intestine  and law intestine we can
digest vegetables as well as fresh food if
almighty god wanted us to have only
vegetables why does he give us vegetables can
digest both further more there
is a misconception that
hindu should not have non veg it is a
misconception if you
read the hindu scripture it is mentioned
in manusmriti chapter number five verse number
30 the almighty god has cut some animals to eat
and some to be killed if you eat the animals that have been cut
to be killed
you are not doing a sin it manusmriti
chapter number five verse number 40 that killing in
sacrifice is not a sin there are various
references in the hindu scripture and the
Vedas that the sages and sages gave non-veg then added
beef if you read Mahabharata Anushasana Parva chapter
number 88 you know the story of the Pandavas no
Pandavas five brothers the elder brother
Yudhishthir he ask Bhishma that what should we give
in yajana in
puja so that our ancestors will be
satisfied then Bhishma reply that if you give
herbs and herbs and vegetable bills our
ancestors will be satisfied for one
month if you give fish for two months if you give
meat for three months if you give hay rabbit
for four months if you give goat for five
months if you give bacon for six months if
you give birds for six months if you give
deer for one month and the menu continues if you
give buffalo for 11 months if you give cow for
Ancestors will be satisfied for one full
year
and if you want ancestors to be
satisfied then give red meat of goat and
nuts
to your the full menu it is there vegetables
fish rabbit goat everything it is there buffalo cow
so even in Hindu scriptures eating non veg is
permitted it is many of the Hindus because they being ill
by other philosophy
prefer plant life to any living
creature i.e. any human being living life living creature animal life protects a lot
in plant life
so by eating vegetable killing life also
but logic no one understands plant gut
life but the plant's feel pain killing
plant is less than killing animal for
sec our argument agrees so
the human year can eat
frequency between 20 cycles per second to
20000 cycles per second anything below and  Now what is the use of
the plant in the human body? The plant cannot be
killed. So there was a farmer in the USA who
converted the plant
to the human body. And it also required
water. Some ok ok fine. I agree that the plant
can feel pain but you know it has two or three
senses. Less then killing a plant is a lesser sin
than killing an animal. Less then one sense.
Second of argument I agree to say less then one cup of animal. I am asking you questions. Suppose my
brother is fooled if he is
deaf and
dumb and does not grow up someone comes and kills him, will you
go and kill him? The judge will give him less
punishment because my brother is
deaf and dumb. Will you tell him the judge will give him a
bigger punishment because my brother is
innocent? He could not speak so in an
environment. It does not work like the two to three.
Senses less Allah says in the Quran in Sura
Baqarah Chapter 2 Verse number 168 it is the good
thing provided for you what is good what is
then you can have and further more I personally have got no
problem if the non muslim don't want to have
non veg I have got no problem
personally only one they tell me it's a sin and
you tell me it's a t give the reply personally
if the non muslims continue having veg it's
good for me if all the non muslims start having
non-veg the